thank you
I do want my client here
um I don't have any preference
so it's up to it's up to your clients
they want to be
here
I assumed everybody was already in you
can go ahead and let them in
oh he's just going through the
guidelines okay
thank you
and just to verify with the court TV and
with the AP reporter
if you or the AP photographer if you
could let me if you could listen to me
for just a minute
um no I mean I I know this goes without
saying but no pictures of the jury
thank you
they're just being briefed right now
Jody
okay
all right I think we've got everyone in
here that wants to come in if you could
be seated and I'd like to just say a few
things before we call the jury in there
is a verdict in the case
I think you've all been told that
when the before the jury enters I just
want to say a few things that I say in
every case the court appreciates that
this has been a long and difficult trial
for the parties
and their counsel
and that emotions may be running High
the court reminds everyone that there
should be no outward reaction when the
verdict is read
and that these proceedings are not over
until the court has been adjourned
most importantly and regardless of the
verdict
the jury has sacrificed
more than eight days of their time to
serve and they are entitled to be shown
the same courtesy and respect
that they have been shown throughout
these proceedings
I want to remind the people that are all
here that there are strict orders that
are in place concerning the use of
phones
cameras recording devices unless you've
been approved and there are only two
people in here that have been approved
for capturing anything by by video by
Audio or by still you should not use
your cell phone or any other device that
might capture those things
thank you
ready for the jury
and I have been impressed with how well
everyone has been throughout this
proceeding so thank you all
okay
for those that are arriving late there's
no use of any recording devices at all
Fitness
for sure
thank you
for the record the jury is now in the
courtroom and the parties are present
with their attorneys
with the four person that the jury has
selected please stand and state your
number
thank you
has the jury reached a verdict
will you please hand it to the bailiff
and the bailiff will bring it to me
thank you you may be seated
thank you we'll now have the clerk read
the verdict
was Gwyneth Paltrow at fault no
was Gwyneth Paltrow's fault a cause of
Terry sanderson's harm
no response there
was Terry Sanderson at fault yes
it was Terry sanderson's fault it caused
Gwyneth Paltrow's
did um did Terry sanderson's fault cause
Gwyneth Paltrow's harm yes
comparative fault
what percent of the fault do you assign
to Terry Sanderson
100 percent
damages what amount fairly
compensates Gwyneth Paltrow for economic
damages one dollar
signed March 30th 2023.
thank you
so to me to juror number 19 the poor
person is this your verdict
yes thank you and the attorneys have
asked that I pull the jury and so I need
to ask each one of you if this is your
verdict
is not an unusual thing to happen it
happens quite often so number 16 is this
your verdict yes thank you number 11 is
this your verdict yes your honor
number eight is this your verdict yes
your honor number two is this your
verdict yes
I've already covered number 19.
number 28 is this your verdict yes
number 29 is this your verdict yes
yes and number 32 is this your verdict
yes your honor thank you
so to the attorneys is there anything
further before I discharge the jury
looking for the plaintiff no thank you
your honor okay thank you
let me just read you the last jury
instruction
ladies and gentlemen of the jury this
trial is finished
thank you for your service
the American system of justice relies on
your time and your sound judgment
and you have been generous with both
you serve Justice by your fair and
impartial decision
I hope you found the experience
rewarding
you may now talk about this case with
anyone you like
you may be contacted by the press or by
the lawyers
you do not have to talk to them
or with anyone else but you may
the choice is entirely yours
I turn now to the lawyers
and to the Press
and ask them to honor your wishes if you
say that you do not want to talk about
the case
if you do decide to talk about the case
please respect the privacy of the of
your fellow jurors
the confidences that they may have
shared with you while deliberating are
not yours to share with others
again thank you for your service
you may now retire
and if everybody else would please
remain here we've got some things to do
may be seated
so uh
I've got a few things I'm going to do
with the parties and then I'm going to
ask everyone who's still in the
courtroom at that point to remain seated
while the parties leave so anyone who
wants to be outside when the parties
leave please do that now
so Mr Owens I'm looking to you to
prepare a judgment on the jury verdict
perfect will you do that yes okay
Mr Sykes is there anything further for
the court before the court adjourns
no my my client just wants to say thank
you to your honor for the effort you
made too okay okay thank you Mr Owens is
there anything further from the defense
before the court adjourned no thank you
judge and to all your staff in the
bailiffs let me just comment that I
appreciate the professionalism that all
the attorneys have shown and the parties
so thank you
this court has now adjourned thank you
about before
yes everyone remains seated well the
parties leave I'm gonna make a quick
statement Miss Paltrow is not going to
be making a statement today
so you can make the statement outside Mr
Owens I will do that okay
all right we're now adjourned